you look incredible a lot of people
worked very hard
you're a nominee so you got to get you
got to do it right tonight
right tonight my hair makeup have people
been walking up and singing to you a lot
more since mega dune uh
no but i wish you wish okay let's do it
let's do it how does it feel to be here
tonight
i can't sing back yet i'm i have no
voice left i have the nerves
she's the nominee tonight kevin would
you let her be beautiful
and like excited about the table uh
sitting with friends yeah i'd only have
to look now i think we're early our
category so then i can i just have to
look damn cast is nominated cecily it
was a tough year and uh i'm really proud
of everybody and i'm proud to be here
with them you also your book is very
open and honest you did not hold
anything back did you no i think um
that's one thing i was like if whatever
i
can't do in writing i can make up for
and being very honest and
you know and it was i'm sharing my
cousin owen and that's at the heart of
it and his girlfriend stacia is doing a
um her go and strong ride tonight so i
want to say go stacia she's raising
money for glioblastoma research
that is great yeah
lots of you know lots of speculation
will you be back what are we it's still
we're still figuring it out whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what does
that mean
well it means i i'm thinking it will
probably happen but it's still you know
and nothing's efficient i was going to
say because that three minutes and 46
seconds of television you did the janine
bureau song one of the
best things i've ever seen in my life it
was the crowd was amazing it was our
first time with the full audience it was
so emotional they were standing through
the whole beginning and it was just i
think that was
one of the most magical experiences it
felt like a goodbye
i know people are telling me that i
didn't mean it that way necessarily
yeah well then can we say goodbye to the
year instead of us yeah can we say good
luck tonight
i know you're nervous you see what i did
with everybody
beautiful
[Music]
you